I love Ryan Murphy and his commitment to
diversity and inclusion both in front of
and behind him if all three of you could
sort of talk about that and what that
means to you how do you if we could
start with you well I don't know what to
say I don't know he's a champion I mean
I am NOT in the I'm not in the position
of the people that he champions right I
am a white woman I am NOT transgender I
am NOT you know what while I was a geek
when I was not a geek but a bohemian
when I was in high school I was an
outcast in high school the fact that he
that he celebrates the fringe in this
country or around the world is
unbelievable because I know what I went
through as a kid um I know the kind of
emotional abuse I went through because I
was different um I'd fought back though
because I'm an Italian I fought back but
it still left a mark I can only say that
that if there should be more Ryan
Murphy's there should be one Ryan Murphy
but there should be more the file follow
his lead
in celebrating everybody's soul he
surrounds you with the most talented
crew and the most talented directors and
the most talented actors and there for
the most part people that he's worked
with before or he has a knack for
finding people from strange you know
sort of strange situations I feel kind
of like one of them I don't really know
how he stumbled upon me for the
politician but to get to meet and work
with all of these people who come from
very different backgrounds and have very
different angles on his material and to
have him as obviously the Lord and
Savior of Ryan Murphy television have
him bring them in and say I want to hear
what you have to say and I want you to
take control you know Janet mock is a
great example terrific director and
writer who worked on the politician and
Hollywood
and you know without her angle her
perspective would not have been the show
that it was and I know that was really
important for for Jeremy at least Jeremy
and Laura I think to have you know a
black woman in the writers room to write
this very important part of the show
which is the angle the perspective of
marginalized black artists in 1947
so really key that he does it and
amazing that he finds so many talented
people to bring together in one room I
think that he really is so inclusive in
every single part of Ryan Murphy
television behind the camera in front of
the camera and I think he is doing work
that really very few are doing in
Hollywood and he is blazing a trail and
I think that he's making change and
change is coming and changes here one of
the things that I don't know if any of
you guys read comic books when you were
growing up but there was a comic book
called what it and it was like what if
Batman had defeated Superman and raised
cattle or you know it's like basically
all versions of history and I felt that
Hollywood was a what if comic except
instead of about superheroes it was what
if Hollywood had embraced diversity and
sexuality in the 1940s and I wanted to
know if any of you guys could sort of
talk about that I don't know maybe a
strong feel I think it's one of the one
of the greatest uses of storytelling
whether it's comic books or cinema is to
take worlds or you know iconic
characters or iconic people and to do
historical fiction with it Ryan is
calling it faction fact plus fiction but
it's basically historical fiction you
take a thing that's true or iconic like
Batman or Superman and you say what if
the thing that we know happens you know
you know what if what if Batman's
parents didn't get killed you know to
follow that that counterfactual which
you don't get to do in real life you
have one timeline in real life and so
you never get to know what would have
happened really all you can do is
imagine but when you have
talented slightly crazy people like Ryan
imagining that you get to see this
amazing you know alternate reality and
you know at very least it's fun and and
exciting and you feel like you've been
taken on a journey and in addition you
maybe learn a little bit about what
might actually could have happened and
maybe informs your your your current
reality Patti I loved your work
I loved your character and I love the
way she ran the studio and I thought she
had just such a great one
how much did you know going in about the
way everything was going to go out this
also applies to everyone like the arc of
everything and how much was it script by
script not script by script but I the
arc of the character that was the pitch
that Ryan pitch to me the arc but the
sad thing for me about doing film is
that we don't get everything at once so
as you know as actors it would be really
great to to track our character so that
when because you know your shoot out of
order and and I'm going oh oh if only
I'd done that because I didn't know what
we was doing this you know I mean so we
didn't have each script in our hands we
didn't know you know like when we were
shooting one we didn't have to when we
were shooting to win enough free time to
doctors in the dark to to increase their
excitement when they get the script
you're finding it out just like the
audience is gonna find it out which I
agree is a mixed bag as an actor you
would like to know you know where you're
gonna end up so you can yeah yeah
exactly exactly
okay what do you think yeah I mean I
think the show really evolved as we as
we shot it you know yeah I think that I
think maybe when we started it was one
show and then it really evolved into
something else which i think is better
and that's the great thing about working
with Ryan he sort of sees the show and
then he kind of reimagines it as we go
and he writes four characters as he sees
them I think that he saw padding saw her
brilliance and started writing for her
so I think it's and that's fantastic and
dangerous and I think that's the Ryan
Murphy world you know where it is it's
not it's not set in stone you know it's
all mouthless are a lot of moving parts
and that's the most exciting thing I
think about working with him I know what
I'm about out of time is real quick
David I was a big fan at the politician
bill and I know you're in season one but
David you're in season two for sure what
can you tease people about it they
didn't give me any scripts they they
just had me show up and I wore a
blindfold the whole time I don't know
it'll be it'll be fun it's very
different you've got a lot of a lot of
the new characters that were introduced
at the end of the season one Judith
Light and and how am i blanking on her
thank you
and she's just knocks her own name right
out of my brain so you've got a lot more
of them you've got the same wonderful
people I miss them so much the same
wonderful kids who are sort of grown up
in this season and yeah I'll be excited
to find out as everybody else will be
the summer I think if everything is Oh
still on schedule but I don't know I
ryan told me this up I spoke to him for
Holly on that note Congrats on the
series you guys have a fantastic day
thank you for giving me your time